Speaker 1: There's a fascinating docu series
soon to be released about the Trump family.
I genuinely am looking forward to this.
There's not a lot of stuff like this that
I look forward to.
The Politico playbook was able to exclusively
obtain footage, sort of like a two minute
trailer from a docu series about the Trump
family and the Trump riots.
This was produced by Alex Holder.
It's called Unprecedented.
It's a it.
Alex Holder is a British filmmaker.
It's going to be on Discovery.
Plus, let's check out the trailer.
This is really, really interesting stuff.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 4: Do you see this line?
Speaker 2: Tyler.
I did evangelicals for Trump, then I did Indian-Americans
for Trump than I did Asian Pacific Americans
for Trump.
My father.
Unidentified: The people's president.
He will make liberals cry again.
Speaker 2: I they you to have the water in
the picture.
You can take an.
In the family.
We've done 55 events in 48 hours.
The campaign basically was a family operation,
washing my hands after giving a bunch of fist
bumps, you know?
Okay.
Yeah, I suppose they could happen.
Speaker 4: Maybe I should.
Just like my God to have the dog on my lap.
Can I borrow your dog?
Can I borrow vodka strokes?
That's why I.
Speaker 2: Put the table back and put the
water under table without the thing on top
of it.
Speaker 4: This is a business, so this feels
good where you have to be in it for the right
reasons.
Speaker 2: This is a fraud on the American
public, the sake of this country where you
get these guys.
Let's kick some ass.
Let's win the game.
Let's walk down Pennsylvania Avenue.
They threw the damn match.
You got to get the roaches out.
Speaker 4: All of them, when you can manipulate
people.
That has consequences.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump was able to use his
children as the embodiment of Trump, the brand.
He's an unconventional person.
He believes that everything that he's doing
is right.
As I look, Trump has always looked at his
project as a dynastic one.
They have a base.
They have their own base.
People have no idea how hard this family work
is part of my base.
Now.
Right.
Let's go.
Do you miss me yet?
Do you.
Speaker 1: Miss me?
I think this is going to be absolutely fascinating.
And to be perfectly honest, the trailer looks
like a mockumentary.
I mean, when you see some of these shots of
the behind the scenes of Trump figuring out
how he wants to sit in, whether he wants water
next to him or whatever.
It seems like a mockumentary, but these people
were in power for four years.
They might be in power again.
And I think it's going to be an absolutely
fascinating docu series.
I'm looking forward to it.
Will review it when it finally comes out.